قال رئيس الوزراء الاثيوبيه باحمد انه
اجرى محادثات هاتفيه مع كل من قائد الجيش
السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد قوات
الدعم السريع محمد حمدان
وقال ابي احمد المحادثات تناول التسويه
الخلافات وديا وتحقيق الاستقرار في
السودان
وكان قائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدان
حنيتي قد قال في تغريده انه ناقش الازمه
في السودان مع رئيس الوزراء الاثيوبي الذي
اكد اهميه ايجاد حل للازمه من اجل استقرار
السودان والمنطقه مبدئيا استعداد اديس ابا
للمساعده في حل الازمه
ذكر اعلام مجلس السياده ان رئيس المجلس
عبد الفتاح البرهان تلقى اتصالات من رئيس
دوله جنوب السودان ورئيس الوزراء الاثيوبي
ورئيس الحكومه الانتقاليه رئيس دوله
الامارات وان بعض المتصلين اكدوا على
ضروره عوده الاوضاع الى طبيعتها في
السودان
واصدرت الاليه ثلاثيه المكونات من الاتحاد
الافريقي والامم المتحده والهيئه الحكوميه
الدوليه المعنيه بالتنميه ايجاد والمجموعه
الرباعيه المكونه من السعوديه والامارات
وبريطانيا والولايات المتحده اصدر بيانا
رحبوا فيه باعلان الجيش السوداني وقوه
الدعم السريع تمديد الهدنه لمده ثلاثه
ايام كما رحب البيانو بابداء كل من القوات
المسلحه السودانيه وقوه الدعم السريع
استعدادا للدخول في حوار لوقف القتال بشكل
دائم وضمان وصول المساعدات الانسانيه دون
عوائق وذكر البيان ان الترتيبات الانسانيه
ستساهم في تطوير خطه خفض التصعيد الوارده
في بيان الاتحاد الافريقي في العشرين من
الشهر الجاري والذي اقرته الجامعه العربيه
والاتحاد الاوروبي والشركاء الدوليون
من مدينه الاثيوبيه مدير مكتبه الجزيره
محمد طه توكل ينضم الينا محمد ما الذي
هيرصدته في هذه الساعات
هناك اهتمام غير مسبوق من الاتحاد
الافريقي وايجاد وريسيا الدوري العالي
للاتحاد الافريقي
وفي مناشد مباشره من رئيس المفوضيه
الاتحاد الافريقي موسى فقهي قبل قليل
الطلبه فيها قاده القوات المسلحه وقاده
قوات الدعم السريع بوقف فوري للقتال وعبر
عن قلقه لمحاصره المدنيين في خرطوم وما
يترتب عليهم من الواقع على الانساني
الماساوي حسب وصف مواصفاته وطالب وقف فوري
لهذا القتال الذي يلحق ضرر بالمدنيين
وايضا ناشد الدول الجوار والمجتمع الدولي
لتقديم مساعدات ودعم سريع للهاربين من هذا
الحرب في ذات السياق طبعا ايضا منظمه
الايجاد وما يعرف بالاليه السياسيه اصدر
وبيان ناشدوا فيها وقف فوري لهذا القتال
فهناك في مساعي
وتيره
عاليه من الاتصالات بين الاتحاد الافريقي
والاتحاد الاوروبي والامم المتحده واكبر
تحدي يواجه الاتحاد الافريقي مجلس الامن
وسلم للمره الاولى يجد انفسهم في معركه لا
يستطيعون الدخول
نتيجه عدم وجود ممر امن لوصول الوسطاء
فبالتالي يشعر بقلق شديد لليوم الثالث عشر
يدخل القتال واكثر من 12 مليون محاصرين
فبالتالي مجلس الامن والسلم في حاله عقب
مستمر
وامس ناقشوا ووجهه الرساله وطلبوا من
الجانب فهم حتى هذه اللحظه لا يريدون
اتخاذ اجراءات فرد عقوبات على من
يعتقدونهم انهم يتسببوا في هذا حتى
لانه هناك في مدينه محاصره واكثر من تسعه
مليون مواطن موجودين وايضا الات افريقيا
يعرف موقع السودان وتاثيره ربما قد يؤثر
الحدث الجاري الان في السودان حسب الاتحاد
الافريقي على اكثر من 150 مليون فبالتالي
حتى تكون هناك فوضى وايضا الاتحاد
الاوروبي ايضا هو شديد الاهتمام لانه
تدافع الملايين من البشر سواء عبر مصر
سواء عبر اثيوبيا سواء عبري
ليفيا بالاضافه طبعا يوجد فقط مواطنين
افارقه من اريتريا واثيوبيا وجنوب السودان
اكثر من خمسه سته مليون بجانب المواطنين
من الدول الافريقيه الاخرى فبالتالي هناك
قلق حقيقي
ولا يعرف ماذا يمكن يعمل مياده لانه
للحوار مع
قاده الجيش او قاده الدعم السريع منقطع
فبالتالي الكل محتمي في الخرطوم في بالذات
في الخرطوم في العاصمه المثلثه في خرطوم
جنوب الخرطوم اغلبيه القدم موجودين
فبالتالي كيف يمكن الحوار معهم فالاتحاد
الافريقي في حاله حيره ولا يريد ان يتخذ
قرار حتى لا يلحق ضرر بالمدنيين مياده
شكرا جزيلا لك من مدينه
مكتبه الجزيره محمد طه توكل